l a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su
è previsto anche se in teoria doveva
uscire ieri ragazzi ma ieri stavano tipo
facendo un aggiornamento non so che
cazzo stanno facendo
infatti se vedete sono cambiate un case
da una sera sto registrando a cazzo dopo
ragazzi fate finta di niente comunque
anno hanno aggiunto delle teste delle
teste va bene comunque ci sono le tre
grandi ma niente adesso mi fanno vedere
il personaggio che è che dovrei dovrei
giocare in ogni livello tipo in cui che
vi si vedono tutti i livelli che sono
giocati la stu personaggio mi chiama
figata per chi se ne fotte dai basta
strozzate
andiamo a giocare prima che che che mimì
l'est jetpack run devo andare si va stai
calmo cazzo ragazzi siamo sono partito a
carne amica senza è bellissimo perché
sembra un dondolo a caso di fare cioè di
porca [ __ ] anche tu mi sembra mi sembra
un birillo cioè non è staff e lui sta
fermo si muove così che due [ __ ]
però alla strada un attimo verso
l'infinito è sticazzi minchia sto per
toccare soprattutto ma [ __ ]
regalone non è così difficile non sono
una idea del perché non ci riesco
aspettate un attimo vuoi donna
[Musica]
ok va bene così non importa non lo so
non so come ho fatto con noi da non me
ne frega niente
troppo difficile me lo stai chiedendo
sul serio t che ti faccio un culo canone
idea comunque è partito gli orchi cazzo
che dovevo farlo lasciarmi mai 3212
figlia che chi è chiesta alto di merda
da york vaio ma che cazzo fa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ragazzi aspettano un attimo che sto mi
chiami girarmi gira la testa forza cosa
basta io ci rinuncio non sono capace non
me ne frega niente è più il sorriso 1.1
questo mi ispira regala dobbiamo andare
a federativo che però a prenderlo poi di
vedere chi sei non mi chiara ghazi
dispiaccio di straccio di brutto
levatevi pezzenti che non siete altro
fatevi strada che caxxo fatto fatto usa
ragazzi sta facendo tutto lui non è
normale comunque io vorrei capire perché
c'è un livello così prendi sotto ed f
cos'è sta roba ragazzi andiamo a farmi
fare i falli che c'è di che sta per
esplodere
ragazzi questo è il tennis più bello che
abbia mai visto
devo ad aa devo mandare la palla di là
ok allora lo peso che cazzo io pensavo
di essere lo penso erano fermi un attimo
che la cosa è troppo figo
ok ok no no la thema questa boomerang
molena palla mi torna indietro
[ __ ] nonno flash bmx parquet con
cosa vuole farmelo fare con nonno
jacques chiamati spiegatemi come si fa a
pari livello così come non c'è anche una
cosa impossibile
è un fenomeno basta avere yo yo no
ognuno puliti nella mia vita tranne
nonno ciak è una cosa indecente
ma come si fa a non amare una persona
era una brava persona ma devi capire
come un vecchio di 80 anni possa fare
questo è una chioma che non riuscirò mai
a capire effettivamente una femmina
dinamica su il bravo bravo bravo papà
cosa fa si lascia ragazzi e fa tutto lui
tutto lui sticazzi che botta ragazzi e
ragazze
ok abbiamo finito desolation che cazzo
ed isole o dio dice lisa mi sembra di
giocare di craxi il caf doveva temo che
non è successo baccani canicani cagni è
tutto a posto
è una casa che cazzo
siamo nella merda e di cazzo cazzo è
ragazzi a questo è un tipo che di sicuro
stava più comodo prima ma non importa
perché usava la mia mente perché la
torcia di punta in alto e non vedo un
cazzo
cioè tu mi devi far pagare addosso per
25 secondi di merda
c'è una cosa sì va beh siamo tornati dal
tizio nel frattempo buongiorno mk
fatality che cazzo vuol dire ai
favoritismi piano ok stanno inglobando
quei due che cazzo fa o dio ragazzi san
siro fantastico bello bellissimo ragazzi
bellissimi
io questo lo vorrei incorniciare in
qualche si può campioni
vai scorge comunità che disastro e ci
abbiamo anche il nobel come la voi la
pizza ok non fa niente questo ragazzi
questo fa la figlia di me ecco lo sapevo
è una cosa ragazzi io agli asili ve li
diamo perché sono troppo strani through
the words i gay perché mi sta
traballando una gamba devo pensare male
perché c'è una gamba che che che già
staccata in partenza non lo so
[ __ ] totti è una casa ok perfetto
non lo fai disastri
lo sapevo sapevo che andava tengono
parvi in qualche modo era è sicuro da
temi del cibo ma [ __ ] prendi di
questo è una madonna che cosa brutta
però però secondo me si sono innamorati
è una cosa hai un presentimento ma che
chiari e ne sono passati al livello
successivo è neanche usarla per ragazzi
facciamo vitali lo si può andateci piano
lega ci sono anche dei bambini era mi
fermi che un disastro se avrò vinto ha
vinto non scassa del cazzo vinto è la
quale come si fa si vabbè ma non importa
lega tanto vinto vabbè non si può
vincere cioè non mi arriva la scritta
vittoria ma noi lo sappiamo e non c'è
problema basketball challenge che cazzo
mi significa prezzo z aperta a pochi
però sta palla per cristina
qualcuno mi spieghi senso di questo allo
ragazzi si si si
eva peso troppo sto pallone sticazzi
grosso tre volte me ma guarda che merda
[Musica]
ragazze e ragazzi da domani in basket si
vince facendo canestro con se stessi
perché se non va bene ma se io tifo
milan cia si così o se mi chiamano non
ha neanche fatto canestro ma va bene
così efficace è un inseguimento con
l'ascia borghezio è una bambina allora
la mamma non se l'ha detto che non si
gioca con lecce ma fanku ecco questo è
quello che succede se i bambini il gioco
ok perfetto se i bambini giocano con le
asce non ti è chiaro perché ma la vostra
mamma che cazzo mi da da mangiare a
colazione fatemi capire perché i bambini
di oggi sono così violenti ragazzi
perché è colpa di gta ammette teles
colpa sua
guarda le orge bastardi niente caramella
ad halloween stronzi sull'elicottero e
la madonna che casa in invasione un
attimo che non salire sull'elicottero
fate perché mi è cresciuta una coda a
caso non rientra da un amico mio parti
senza di me perché io non riesco a
salire una cazzo di scala e nagaoka ok
ce l'abbiamo fatta
sì ma alza alcuno distali cotter non è
possibile se no no no no ma guarda che
bastardo e allora siete poteva ma io
scherzavo prima non devi decollare
veramente testa di minchia madonna
ragazzi murdoch e solidarietà del mio
culo wii wheel of doom è una cosa io mi
aggrappo la tua testa tanto è dura e
quindi ce la possiamo fare allora tu
redditi ok bravo
la cosa cazzo avevo detto ed evidenza
sui suoi studi l'ho sempre detto che ci
sono persone che perdono la testa per me
è una cosa o che questa era pessimo e
cazzo che faccio di questa mappa ncolas
e se non riuscissi tipo a saltare in
questi casi bye bye
mica che che mira della madonna crash dr
devo prendere anno devo prendere sto
coso fermi fermi fermi eccolo qua l'ho
preso proprio sul mento fantasma e sono
riuscito a vincere light lightweight
vediamo con enti che la prima volta che
fa un volo
allora ragazzi sedetevi comodi e
godiamoci il viaggio e la gara tutto
normale tutto tranquillo ma se c'è
qualcosa la tv non danno alla tv
sull'aereo che hanno perché no
richiudete finestrino
basta tutta storia e che cazzo è una
cosa no perché vittoria dario durato
pochissimo cazzo siamo c'è un iphone 5
che cazzo ci fa 20 play sorprese
presagio 232 del 1800 bolca [ __ ] ho
dimenticato le chiavi nella mattino un
cazzo ragazzi questo non è un bambino
normale è una cosa dove che cazzo
successo lo sai cos'è successo dove
siamo
lui è cattivo che cate sì ma stai jarmo
cazzo che ti arriva un lavandino in
testa veramente una cosa devo fare
uscita a usa perfetto è stato solo un
brutto sogno è fantastico ok però tra
kulaki cazzola invitato vabbè ragazzi
proviene 1 mio perché era ancora fa vj
prova questa vai così brava a cazzo
proprio picchiato che perfetto direi che
ho sbagliato un po personaggio ma non ne
so non ne sono completamente convinto e
aspettate un attimo
facciamo così ciancio una soluzione vai
donna lancia mi lancio viva allora sei
proprio inutile mi devi lanciare lancia
mio dio allora facciamo così un bacino
ha un bacino aperte un bacino sulle
tette così però primati poi un
pochettino hd quella [ __ ] vai su
maledizione facciamo finta di non la
cambiamo personaggio tanto non ha senso
by steve ce l'ho fatta vabbè mica
speriamo il perché da mezz'ora che sono
sotto livello ancora non ho fatto un
salto
ma possibile che non riesco a fare il
va bene così non lo voglio più vedere il
suo livello
vj toilet run che dire poi vigenti 100
kb il treviso mi fanno morire la pioggia
dei celti perfetto sono diventato un
gabinetto portatile non ha un cazzo di
senso fatemi fatemi l'ultima faccio
l'ultimo perché fa vj prove lo fa per
favore prova almeno una volta lo provo
ok ho provato una volta non aver scherzo
ci provo ci prova un altro allora porca
[ __ ] se non si esce ma un k donna
allora non sono io stupido
sì sono io stupido probabilmente non lo
so per favi gemma non si esce premi
subito la freccetta in giù tra anche
scritte effettivamente sono io che non
so leggere ve ne do atto per madonna che
testa china ha preso tre bombe in testa
non mi sono fatto nulla abbiate pazienza
non lo so perché ma voglio finire suo
livello prima bugia perché sanno fare sì
sì sì madonna green no non era la
vittoria era una presa io mi sono anche
lanciato dalla b si comanda efficiente
ma perché questa questa è stata la
trovata più assurda che mi abbiate mai
fatto perché ora non posso mantoux per
salire mi sono buttato perché credevo
fosse alla fine fantastico grazie mille
regalo concluso qui perché vi giuro
cesto cappello che mi mette un prurito
assurdo non mettere più un cazzo in
testa nei prossimi video perché non ce
la faccio più non crearsi spero che vino
vi sia piaciuto io concludo più
l'episodio come al solito ragazzi se vi
è piaciuto sotto un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come non i
video tratte nella descrizione cerazione
tedeschi di scrivete noi ci mettiamo in
questo video belle ragazze